on va commencer par la poêle maintenant
j'en ma mère avec une course
complètement folle on dit que c'est la
course du siècle c'est à dire le vendée
globe challenge 13 navigateurs sont
partis cet après midi pour faire le tour
du monde sans escale sans assistance
moi je résume à ça en un seul mot je
dirais que c'est l'aventuré avec un
grand a
alors ils vont partir pendant 4 -
vraiment tout seul sans croiser haine
qui vive
alors vous me direz c'est l'histoire
d'un dossier c'est l'histoire de ce look
ou à la fin du iième siècle
c'est l'histoire des grands qui nous ont
fait rêver de la mer c'est un peu de la
folie aussi pour certains mais si ça
correspond à la folie de chichester par
exemple pour lui la définition de la
folie du marin c'était de dire il part à
condition de ne pas rencontrer les
autres donc c'est un peu ça ils vont
partir vraiment quatre mois tout seul
alors il veut ils vont vraiment faire
rien comme les autres et je vous propose
de les voir ce sont 13 hors du commun
qui ont quitté aux alentours de 15h les
sables d'olonne pour le plus grand
périple le tour de la terre c'est la
main du maître de bon nombre d'entre eux
eric tabarly qui à cet après-midi
libérer les traits aventuriers du globe
challenge 10 français deux américains et
un sud africain
treize marins partis pour des endroits
que la plupart d'entre eux ne
connaissent pas partie se faire mouiller
couché par les vagues peur dans les
coins les plus retirés du monde treize
personnages lancé sur les océans pour le
simple plaisir d'être seul face à la mer
soi même et son bateau si la motivation
et communes les moyens le sont moins
pour jean-luc van den heede la course et
à ses frais il part sans sponsor
difficulté aussi pour un autre
patrice carpentier le dernier arrivé il
n'a eu que trois semaines pour vraiment
se préparer il nous sans bateau 15000
francs la semaine sont intéressés donc
de se dépêcher
mais dans une mer déjà formé comme
aujourd'hui avec un vent de plus de 40
kilomètres heure une seule consigne la
prudence car il faut durer un tour
qu'ils espèrent effectuer pour les
meilleurs en 120 jours par les trois
caps sur les trois océans atlantique
indien et pacifique sans croiser âme qui
vive entre les sables-d'olonne départ et
arrivée une aventure encore plus folle
que celle de 1968 lorsque robin knox
johnston est le seul des quatre engagée
à ramener son ketch de 10 mètres swahili
au port de falmouth après 313 jours de
mer une aventure insensée de moitessier
alors qu'il a course gagnée préfère
s'évader partir pour les îles d'où
donald crowhurst l'anglais ne reviendra
jamais mara mythomane il n'annonce que
des positions et rooney il se suicide
avant qu'on ne découvre la supercherie
le tour du monde en solitaire c'est un
rêve un mythe une aventure qui fascine
quelque chose de tellement immense que
jean-yves terlain portant un habitué
préfère en rigoler ils vont partir
pendant 120 jours dans leur petit
intérieur de trois mètres carrés plus ou
moins décoré tout en trompe l'oeil pour
loïck peyron plus fonctionnel et éclairé
pour titouan lamazou proche de l'an 2000
pour philippe poupon
pour certains on entre dans le v dans le
21e siècle
mais pour d'autres comme chez jean luc
van den aide ce serait plutôt le 19e
siècle dépouillement total et simplicité
que dire alors de jean françois coste
abords de cacharel l'ancien peine du 3
le plus petit et le plus vieux bateau de
la course quatre mois à vivre au sol
pour la cuisine le ménage la mise au
point le bricolage dans n'importe
quelles conditions
et partout
bien mais tout est prévu tout près pour
éviter toute agression d'humidité tous
les vêtements toutes les pièces
électroniques toutes les piles tout tout
tout tout tout va sous vide même les
petites barres de chocolat et de
noisettes sersou liszt est déjà emballée
plus encore sous vide
il vaut mieux car les conditions seront
souvent extrêmes seul face aux éléments
ils pourront toujours faire la fête au
passage de l'équateur le jour de noël le
1er janvier ou encore au passage du horn
mais tout cela sans jamais s'arrêter et
ils l'ancien manceau est louable que
jamais s'arrêter de de s'isoler
complètement et de vraiment de vouloir
vivre cette histoire un homme un bateau
aux océans c'est de la surenchère pour
l' aventure mais surtout pour cette
espèce de communion avec ce bateau
aujourd'hui c'est la dernière fois
qu'ils se voient pour quatre mois
ils sont depuis 15h15 seuls face à leur
destin
bonsoir retour donc sur la terre ferme
pour titouan lamazou le navigateur
français a bouclé un tour du monde à la
voile en solitaire et sans escale comme
pour qu'il reste encore un petit peu
avec lui le vent était pratiquement
tombées cet après midi au large des
sables-d'olonne et la patience de ses
parents de ses amis ou ses supporters a
été mise à rude épreuve nous allons
rejoindre tout de suite en direct des
sables d'olonne yves rétif de la station
défaire 3 nantes yves une seule question
est-ce que l'écureuil d'aquitaine a
franchi maintenant la ligne d'arrivée
non marc écureuils d'aquitaine n'a
toujours pas franchi la ligne d'arrivée
c'est une insoutenable attente ici sur
les pontons des sables d'olonne le
bateau est à portée de vue des émetteurs
d'etf r3 vous le découvrirez en même
temps que nous sur ces images les voiles
face oeil
il n'avance pas il n'y a pas de brises
thermiques il est à quelques hauts même
pas un mille peut-être de la ligne
d'arrivée c'est très trompeur bien sûr
avec ces images nocturnes les petits
vaisseaux qui sont autour sont ceux des
bateaux qui l'accompagnent on l'attend
d'une seconde à l'autre peut-être
va-t-il franchir la ligne là en direct
non je le pense pas je n'entends pas les
les klaxons les sirènes qui doivent
saluer cette victoire après 109 jours
seul face à la mer après vingt-six mille
milles nautiques 50000 km un tour du
monde complet
un record battu celui de
kersauson battu de 15 jours et cela avec
un monocoque cette fois ci bref
l'insoutenable suspense continue aussi
aux sables d'olonne de toute façon
l'arrivée n'aura pas lieu dans le port
des sables une fois que titre pour
lamazou sur écureuils d'aquitaine
on va couper la ligne eh bien il faudra
attendre parce que le chenal n'est pas
accessible
nous sommes à marée basse ici dans le
port des sables il nous continuerons
cette nuit pour en savoir davantage il
n'y a pratiquement plus du tout devant
là ce soir aux fans de la bande à lui à
l'instant les images il n'y a plus du
tout devant là on me confirme qu'ils
viennent passer la ligne
titouan lamazou vainqueur du premier
globe challenge le vendée globe
challenge on me confirme à l'instant que
le ça y est il a gagné
vous le vivez en même temps que nous en
ce moment même alors pour l'interviewer
ce sera sans doute un petit peu
difficile
est ce que vous imaginez seulement
l'attention de la famille alors que
philippe poupon viens nous rejoindre à
l'instant venez philippe vous concurrent
malheureux de cette épreuve
philippe qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que
vous vivez là en voyant cette victoire
qui aurait pu être la vôtre
oh non je ne suis pas là je n'ai
cueillir tito inquiets vainqueur cette
course et moi je sais pu me courent ça
s'est arrêté il ya déjà trois mois
celui qui gagne et c'est un grand copain
en question de pardon mais je
retransmettrait l'autre question d'henri
philippe poupon vous avez déjà gagné des
courses importantes est ce que l'on peut
est ce que l'on peut dire ce que je
ressens en ce moment en titouan lamazou
a je crois que c'est difficile bon moi
j'ai connu un petit peu ça mais là je
crois que c'est encore beaucoup plus
fort c'est cette course allait quand
même beaucoup plus de puissance au
niveau du temps passé en mer entre
autres enfin je crois que c'est en 2000
cela va être très dur c'est à la fois le
plaisir de bien sûr d'arriver c'est
c'est une course merveilleuse que voilà
ce qu'on peut essayer de la gagner tito
en ligue 1 c'est super on passe d'un cem
couler ce
amassés ce qui va se passer après la
ligne c'est toute la foule
alors est ce qu'on voudrait savoir
comment on réagit justement après 109
jours de solitude
est-ce qu'il se rend compte qu'il ya
toute l'europe la médiatique qui
l'attend bah oui je pense qu'il le sait
le faire on le savait quelque part on
savait très bien que celui qui allait
gagner cette course allait trouver aux
sables d'olonne
un accueil et puis sur une auto riez tf1
il le sait alors je sais pas si je crois
que c'est personnel
on peut pas livrer sa place très fort
niveau du caractère il va bien bien le
vivre voilà ivre et il fait ce que l'on
peut dire peut-être un mot de me parler
de qui et titouan lamazou c'est un
navigateur un petit peu hors du commun
c'est aussi un peintre c'est aussi un
écrivain c'est un enfant d'aquitaine
avant tout c'est un poète c'est un homme
qui a vécu au maroc vous avez résumé
l'essentiel c'est un petit peu un
surdoué est un touche à tout il réussit
en voile comme il a réussi en poésie en
livres pour enfants comme il voudrait
maintenant se consacrer à la peinture
quelle sera sa vie ensuite on ne le sait
pas on imagine seulement l'intense
émotion en ce moment même de son père de
sa mère de son enfant qui sont là bas
sur une vedette à côté de lui dans la
baie des sables d'olonne alors qu'il
vient de réussir cet exploit
extraordinaire de gagner le premier
vendée globe challenge une
circumnavigation autour du globe
il est vrai tiff merci vous venez donc
de vivre en direct dans ce journal
l'arrivée de titouan lamazou a boy abord
d'écureuil d'aquitaine et puis quand
même au passage un sacré coup de chapeau
à toutes les équipes de la croix qui
depuis ce matin depuis très tôt ce matin
vous font suivre donc cet événement en
direct et vous ont permis ce soir de
voir ces images donc on dirait que la
ligne d'arrivée et la victoire de
titouan lamazou dans le vendée globe
challenge
heureux qui comme gauthier a fait un bon
voyage le skipper français a remporté
aujourd'hui la deuxième édition du
vendée globe en arrivant à 16h24 très
précisément au port des sables d'olonne
terme d'un tour du monde en solitaire
sans escale et sans assistance
environ 46 mille kilomètres parcourus en
110 jours 2 heures 22 minutes et 39
secondes
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux yann
lavoix et jean louis normandin
avec tout d'abord les premières
impressions du vainqueur à terre à terre
depuis une poignée de secondes seulement
le premier regard d'alain gautier va son
bateau à y ait un super bateau et puis
le voir de l'extérieur
retour en arrière 16h20 alain gautier et
à 6 à la barre on imagine le choc pour
ce solitaire escortés par des dizaines
d'embarcations
on imagine la difficulté pour lui de
digérer si rapidement
tous ces instants merveilleux 16h22
c'est la victoire le tour du monde et
bouclé en 110 jours alain d'ordinaire si
réservé extériorise la joie des jambes
le porte de nouveau les premier mots par
radio seront pour philippe jeantot
l'organisateur
saab emploie 700 salariés qui encore une
fois ce seuil comme le départ raté
c'est fantastique
à la fal ses voiles pour entrer
doucement dans le chenal et mieux se
délecter des bravos poussé par des
milliers de vendéens venu faire de ce 12
mars un jour inoubliable
sandrine sa compagne et radieuse les
retrouvailles sont pathétiques mais que
l'ua s'est glissé à l'oreille nouvelle
le retour du bonhomme sur la terre ferme
mérité un plus grand respect mais
personne ne voulait manquer ses premiers
mots qui sont allés à deux blocs
valeureux adversaires à nigel burgess
décédé après quelques jours de cours et
puis au public venu l'accueillir
on sait qu'on va convoyer de bien
accueilli mais ce n'est pas toujours
l'entendement est ce à quoi on pensait
il y avait du respect et de l'admiration
dans les yeux de chacun cet après midi
c'est pas tous les jours que l'on croise
un champion
baa
on mesure encore mieux l'exploit en
rappelant que sur les 14 concurrents au
départ si seulement vont boucler ce tour
du monde en rappelant surtout que cette
course a été endeuillée par une double
disparition celle de mike plant et nigel
burgess les héros du vendée globe nous
en donner au cours de cette année 97 une
immense leçon de courage un tête à tête
entre les marelles grand sud à la fois
grandiose effrayant de gerry roufs
disparu à christophe auguin le vainqueur
de ce tour du monde et sont allés
jusqu'au bout de cette grande aventure
humaine
là
pour moi
c'est effarant et et fascinant à la fois
c'est quelque chose
demain
la hype quelques minutes à faire
et
il est hostile comme ça
jour pareil ça va laisser une
une [ __ ] d'emprunt dans les allées le
rona
à
20h08 michel desjoyeaux coupe la ligne
d'arrivée de ce quatrième vendée globe
les sables d'olonne laisse alors éclater
leur joie
son bateau porte le numéro 85
le département de la vendée une victoire
à domicile en quelque sorte
devant un public nombreux qui attend son
héros depuis le milieu de l'après midi
ils ont bravé la pluie bravé le froid et
maintenant c'est la brume qui gênent la
visibilité
peu importe
et puis discrètement sa femme monte à
bord 93 jours que son navigateur de mari
est parti mais elle n'ose pas le
déranger
bientôt l'équipe h a grandi photo de
famille avec ses trois garçons le titre
est produit à hauteur
déjà j'ai failli ne pas le savoir un
bruit je n'ai plus vraiment au dernier
moment alors que j'avais le traceur
avait tout ce qu'il fallait
je quelques noms encore où s'était
arrêté
comme si c'était un parcours côtier de
l'après midi c'est évident que toute la
proche avec tous les bateaux derrière
c'était vraiment j'ai jamais vu ça et je
crois que j'aurais jamais ça de ma vie
un tour du monde
ça laisse forcément des traces et une
fois à terre michel desjoyeaux est un
peu déboussolés
je crois que l'affairé se bougent d'un
jour à sion bon ben ça doit être moi un
marin qui attendaient encore pendant une
bonne partie de la nuit
madame monsieur bonsoir il n'était pas
le favori et c'est lui qui emporte le
trophée vincent riou est le héros du
jour ou plutôt de la nuit il vient de
franchir la ligne d'arrivée du vendée
globe et le public lui a bien sûr
réservé un triomphe benoît rousset 87
jours 10 heures 47 minutes et 55
secondes le chrono de tous les records
pour vincent riou ils bouclent peu avant
minuit son tour du monde en solitaire en
monocoque sans escale et sans assistance
sur un incroyable exploit premier pour
son premier vendée globe sur prb le
bateau du précédent vainqueur michel
desjoyeaux qui avait mis cinq jours de
plus que lui
vincent riou dit vincent le terrible a
été accueilli en héros aux sables
d'olonne sur la ligne d'arrivée
le navigateur étonnamment calme est
revenu sur son aventure hors du commun
mais trois mois que
24 heures sur 24 on se bagarre et c'est
vrai que c'est usant à la fin est près
d'arriver comme ça en plus alex
d'accueil lasser c'est totalement
magique un fait
ça reste ça c'est des moments
extraordinaires et les vouloir
inoubliable aujourd'hui moi je finis
cette course avec la satisfaction du
travail bien fait c'est vraiment ça mon
c'est vraiment ça qui me fait plaisir
quoi il ya eu la bagarre du début à la
fin on s'est battu il a fallu rester
vraiment vigilant jusqu'à la dernière
minute je dirais même jusqu'à ce matin
où j'étais encore arrêtée dans les
teasers avec jean le cam plus derrière
voilà quoi ce truc c'est toujours pareil
les victoires on se bagarre le plus sont
forcément les plus belles et les
salaires c'était une belle bagarre
incroyable scénario dans cette course
pas comme les autres qui dès le départ
qu'on des allures de régates
les duels entre vincent riou et jean le
cam deux marins au tempérament bien
différent plus avec mike golding auront
dominé ce cinquième vendée globe la
différence vincent riou la fera après le
passage du cap horn
grâce à de meilleures options météo le
suspense de ce final à 3 a donc pris fin
aujourd'hui
vincent riou que savourer son éclatante
victoire dans le chenal des sables
d'olonne où des dizaines de milliers de
personnes sont venues l'accueillir avec
ses proches
vincent riou on va pouvoir enfin
regarder derrière lui et attendre sans
crainte ses deux poursuivants attendus
eux dans les heures qui viennent
dans quelques secondes
là
ainsi s'achève 84 jours et un peu plus
de trois heures de solitude
michel desjoyeaux a remporté le vendée
globe pour la deuxième fois record de
l'épreuve halak les records d'affluence
aussi pour saluer ce marin de 43 ans
cent mille personnes aux sables d'olonne
à terre et en mer à bord du monocoque
l'heure est aux retrouvailles les amis
et la famille quelques secondes
d'intimité à peine avec régine son
épouse dans cette cabine ou michel
desjoyeaux a construit son exploit parti
avec 40 heures de retard
le professeur savoure enfin il y a huit
ans desjoyeaux était arrivé en pleine
nuit cette fois à l'heure du goûter
dominical l'hommage populaire était à la
hauteur de ce brillant champion michel
desjoyeaux ou l'homme volant son
palmarès en fait désormais le skippeur
le plus titré de l'histoire de la voile
pendant que les autres sont encore sur
l'eau lui est déjà passé au champagne
si le vendée globe n'était qu'une partie
de plaisir à force ça se saurait et si
le vendée globe n'était qu'un enfer sas
aurait aussi les marins n'irai pas
simplement entre la ventura risque et la
course de bateaux se glissent de temps à
autre la souffrance le drame et
l'héroïsme lors de la deuxième édition
du vendée globe en 1989 philippe poupon
a déclenché deux balises de détresse
son bateau est couché sur l'eau loïck
peyron se déroute et au prix d'une
manoeuvre audacieuse
il va réussir à redresser les monocoques
en perdition pour repartir à réparer
perreault finira deuxième de la coupe
1992 bertrand de broc va faire de la
couture sur sa langue déchiré par une
blessure
une séance d'auto chirurgie de points de
suture menée grâce aux conseils
prodigués au téléphone par jean yves
chauve le médecin de la course
1996 la troisième édition la plus agitée
du vendée globe au large de l'océan
indien dans le froid et la tempête
l'anglais bullimore après quatre jours
et quatre nuits à temps des reclus à
l'intérieur de son bateau qui avait
chaviré
une frégate de la marine australienne
récupéré sain et sauf grâce à une énorme
détermination et quelques carrés de
chocolat
quelques heures auparavant les secours
australiens hélitreuille le français
thierry dubois qui avait pris place dans
un canot de survie
1996 raphaël dinelli est à bord d'un
bateau qui a pris l'eau miraculeusement
il sera sauvé par l'anglais phil goss
qui se déroute le récupère en pleine mer
et le ramène à bon port en australie
lors de cette édition du vendée globe le
canadien gerry roufs disparaît dans des
conditions dantesques
on retrouvera son bateau jamais la mère
de rendre à son corps
bonsoir françois gabart et merci
énormément d'être avec nous depuis 16h
soit vous enchaîner les interviews avec
une facilité déconcertante
vous avez été seul en mer 78 jours
comment avez vous vécu le retour sur
terre
ce moment vous êtes accueilli par des
dizaines de milliers de personnes aux
sables d'olonne
mais la transition est brutale mais
tellement belle c'est vrai que après
avoir vécu comme ça tout seul sur un
bateau pendant trois mois avec toutes
les difficultés que ça et on arrivait en
voit toute cette foule qui bat qu'à
rêver avec nous qui a qu'à vibrer je
pense pendant pendant ces trois mois de
course et ça fait chaud au coeur ça fait
plaisir merci à toutes les personnes qui
sont venus aujourd'hui sur le chenal des
sables parce que ma grâce à vous j'ai pu
vivre un moment exceptionnel
on vous remercie aussi françois gabart
surtout vous vous êtes aujourd'hui entré
dans la légende
on a entendu plein de compliments
notamment sur votre simplicité votre
humilité
certains vous comparent à eric tabarly
est-ce que vous avez un petit peu peur
de devenir un héros
non je crois percevoir corner ça non je
fais simplement du bateau j'essaye de
faire le bateau le mieux possible
après ben voilà ce qui se dit autour
c'est ça peut éventuellement là en
l'occurrence ça serait ça ne serait que
flatteur donc ça ne me fait pas peur ce
qui nous frappe chez vous c'est que
depuis le début vous avez le sourire
qu'avez-vous appris sur vous pendant ce
tour du monde en solitaire
j'ai appris qu'on était capable de faire
énormément de choses tout seul sur un
bateau j'ai appris que on était capable
de d'aller très vite d'avoir des coups
durs et puis de 2,2 passes et au delà
tout ça de trouver de l'énergie au fond
de soi et puis et puis être fatigué à
nouveau mais ils ont retrouvé encore de
l'énergie
j'ai appris voilà que bach un bonhomme
tout seul sur un bateau était capable de
faire plein de choses et c'est plutôt
très très agréable mais il ya eu des
moments vous avez craqué
craquez craquer au point de ne pas
franchir l'arrivée non les moments
difficiles oui évidemment il ya des
moments difficiles c'est normal mais
voilà j'ai réussi à faire face à chaque
fois à respirer un grand coup puis à
repartir à l'attaqué parce qu'il fallait
fallait rien lâcher
il ya un mais là qui vient d'arriver et
le bruit derrière mais mais voilà là la
course a été très serré avec lui tous
les mêmes quand on arrive à terre voilà
il y avait une compétition qui nous
permettait pas de se libérer et comment
vous avez vécu ce visuel cette
compétition avec armel le cléac'h gelé
très bien vécu enfin c'était difficile
je le cache pas mais je pense qu'on a
vraiment eu pour les compétiteurs que
nous sommes tous les deux je connais
bien mais je sais que c'est un
compétiteur je le suis aussi
on a eu de la chance le privilège
immense d'avoir une une régate à deux
bateaux pendant pendant des semaines et
ça c'est vraiment une chance énorme
je suis très heureux parce qu'en plus
les gagner nos forcément ça ça facilite
un petit peu le jugement mais je pense
qu armel a aussi vécu un beau moment de
voir la commande compétition et et c'est
c'est vraiment vraiment beau à voir et
j'ai hâte de vous quitter après pour
aller les féliciter
elle est allée serrer allez-y foncez
foncé rejoindre votre ami votre copain
armel le cléac'h merci mille fois et
bravo encore on voit d'ailleurs un ces
images en direct qui nous parviennent
des sables d'olonne de l'arrivée ça y
est il est sur terre d'armel le cléac'h
qui a donc lui aussi réalisé un tour du
monde en moins de 80 jours